hier domain of proposé en deuxième
partie de soirée relooking extrême
spécial obésité l'émission gêne beaucoup
de monde dont christophe carrière à
cause des images qui sont diffusées moi
j'ai regardé hier c'est ce que j'ai
regardé hier soir bon j'ai kiffé ma tête
voilà je vous lis pour vous faire une
idée on va regarder quelques extraits
regardez par exemple aux portes et de
rachat c'est ça ou achats chez rachel
entre ces appels étaient très longs
racontant qu'elle se sentait exclu de sa
famille à cause de son poids
regardez wachau je m'appelle rachel j'ai
21 ans et j'ai 100 kilos en trop grand
malade des trucs comme ça
j'ai le sentiment de décevoir mais je
sens bien que ma vie entière est une
déception à cause de sa note et mara 2g
est élue reine de mon bal de promo et
j'ai eu un prix d'excellence colère mais
rien de tout ça il semble pouvoir
compenser le fait que je suis déception
à cause de mon poids je pense que je ne
pourrai jamais rendre quand mes parents
fiers de moi si je ne perde pas mis
kilos en trop alors rachel elle a perdu
73 connaît grâce à l'émission vous allez
voir le changement de rachel dans un
instant pourquoi vous êtes énervé vous
non ce qui m'énerve c'est la surenchère
dans ce genre d'émission bon là c'est
violent mais là je comprends il ya des
cas effectivement d'accord mais là il ya
une 6e temps même qui prépare je sais
pas si vous êtes au conte qui se prépare
qui s'appelle objets qu'ils disent
objectif 10 ans - alors rappelé aux
téléspectateurs c'est christina cordula
le concept c'est faire perdre dix ans à
des français en plus bien dans leur peau
pendant trois semaines des experts vont
tout faire pour rajeunir les
participants médecins esthétiques
dentiste esthétique mais très content ça
veut dire qu'on va inciter des gens qui
sont très bien
voilà qui sont petites mais j'assume pas
à faire dix ans - excusez-moi mais on
est la preuve vivante qu'il ya dix ans
avec dix ans de moins
on était plus moche toi non
vous avez une approche semblable à
l'express ici michael des gouvernements
il pas toujours pour les autres et des
gros convient de maigrir est ce que
c'est morbide
oui c'est une question de vie ou de mort
de maigrir qu'est-ce que tu casses en
afrique on explique jean-michel c'est
que toi même d'ailleurs t'as un ami
chirurgie esthétique je vois là sur un
terrain où il poste des photos de filles
ton dessin absolument superbe tout et
qui doit progresser persia ouais mais
non mais on est complètement écrire et
la chirurgie là vous parlez de deux
choses différentes
oui il est également le seul danger de
la chirurgie esthétique c'est le trouble
identitaire c'est à dire qu'à un moment
donné quand on fait trop si hadji à la
fin les personnes ou celui qui ont
baissé je ne sais plus qui ont aimé moi
je reconnais pas comment cette équipe
des dépressions à cause de sa
phénoménale de maigrir mais la
transformation de rachel a perdu 73 kg
grâce à l'émission vous allez voir que
le changement est impressionnant regarde
mesdames et messieurs applaudissez bien
fort
la nouvelle rachel
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
allez pas mieux
elle est révolue you qui aggravent
pardon amis d'antan dans ce cas là mais
dans l'émission de m6 qui va arriver
avec nouvelle dans nos bassins c'est
qu'on est en train de mettre en avant le
fait que ce qui est superficiel c'est à
dire uniquement la beauté c'est ce qui
est important pour être heureux ce qui
vaut mettre en avant le ghana regarder
m6 en prime time vont se dire si on a
des belles dents qu'on est belle quand
elle est belle hein
c'est comme ça qu'on va réussir
peut-être atteindre 22 la vie mais sinon
c'est pas ça va 74 kg isabelle en la
chantant paysans toi problème de
l'émission que vous extreme heures et le
relooking là c'est que une fois que
l'émission de télévision est passée ils
les laissent notamment en jachère donc
ça on oublie absolument plus alors que
dans les émissions françaises et un
suivi pendant bien sûr c'est pas mal
ontologique pas laisser salir et vitoria
plantes quoi sur un système c'est quand
tu dis que tu es sur le tournage de
bonheur est dans le pré c'est pas vrai
c'est pas tout le match les mains car
qu'est-ce qui vous gêne qu'on rentrerait
ça des gens qui sont malheureux
malheureux il ya un sur voit d'abord ça
coûte de faire qui font comme moi ça oui
maintenant du cast à la cause est
ailleurs aujourd'hui raconte qu'elle
qu'on est là la cause gay le coup mais
qu'est ce que tu racontes 6 et 7 femmes
allez allez malheureuse à la 100 kg trop
personnelle autant faire spectacle
évidemment qu'elle peut pas continuer à
vivre comme ça les malheureux c'est un
exemple c'est une motivation et nous
tout devient matière respecte alors moi
je suis fait faire des grands régimes
peu lente je suis actuellement en train
de faire un régime fasse quoi parce que
j'ai pris du bide parce que je picole et
et l'alcool c'est des sucres donc là ça
fait fait vision sans alcool on verra
témoignages et je vais monter sur scène
et il faut que j'ai une certaine
condition physique je veux me tourner
vers quelqu'un qu'elle veut il a faim
[Applaudissements]
huit jours sans alcool
cette personne a fait huit minutes fait
des régimes avant les tournages un petit
peu tu fais ça mais surtout quand tu
tournes pendant deux ou trois mois il
faut qu'on arrive à tenir ton poids
sinon à l'image ça se voit mais nous
avons un ami proche qui en ce moment est
en train de faire une jolie sèche pour
préparer son spectacle c'est malik
bentalha rui et qui va revenir très beau
il est déjà très beau qui va être encore
plus beau malik bentalha mb voilà on
l'envoie je vais regarder les temps